♪ ♪ ♪
Cet ent,t,t, c'est Korogocho,
l'un des plus gros bidonvilles
(bêlements)
Un amoncellement chaotique
de fortune, plantées tout autour
d'un énorme dépotoir.
Un lieu de vie pour près de
comme Elvis Otieno.
♪ ♪ ♪
Korogocho, c'est aussi
le siège d'un orchestre pas
comme les autres.
♪ ♪ ♪Le Ghetto Classics Orchest,
formé entièrement de jeunes
Un ensemble musical mais aussi,
et d'abord, une école.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est ici qu'Elvis a tout
appris. Un amour et une passion
à son tour à des jeunes
qui ont tout à apprendre.
♪ ♪ ♪
Des jeunes c
et Simon Mwangi.
Avec le solfège, c'est tout
un univers
♪ ♪ ♪
Avec la musique,nnnnnnnnnnnnnnnt
la rigueur, la routine.
Le dur labeur aussi que
représentent les répétitionsdide
idéales, car l'orchestre
s'est installé là où vivent
gros dépotoir de l'Est africain,
constamment exposé à des fumées
♪ ♪ ♪
Un contexte difficile
qui a forgé la déterminationngn.
Son instrument est devenu
une passion, une obsession.
Autrefois déheheheur, il est
aujourd'hui un élève modèle.
Depuis qu'
à la clarinette, Simon s'est
transforMêMêMême sa mère
ne le reconnaît plus.
(appla
(klaxon)
Aujourd'hui, s'est avec
enthousiasme q
se lève tous les matins
et qu'il trsrsrse le bidonville
de Korogocho pour se rendre
à l'éco
à la saleté, à la pauvreté
qui l'ururure, porté par
l'ambition et le rêve.
Et toute la semaine, il attenda.
(musique de l'orchestre)
ses amis de l'orchestre du
ghetto pour jouer ensemble.
L'orchestre s'est déjà produit
à l'étranger, a déjà joué pour
♪ ♪ ♪
Le but des Ghetto Classicsclclce
ououous ces élèves des musiciens
professionnels. ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪♪
La musique est d'abord
un outil, un moyen d'élargir
que tout un monde tetete
en dehors du ghetto et
♪ ♪ ♪
Depuis sa fondation en 2008,
l'institution a formé plus de
comme Elvis, en ont fait
une carrière. Mais l'un des plus
importants accomplissements de
Ghetto Classics, c'est d'avoir
redonné auunununes du bidonville
le droit de rêver et, surtout,
les rêves peuvent se réaliser.
♪ ♪